ramadan ist luca herzlich willkommen wir
heute meine damen und herren zu einem
spiel das ich seit monaten nicht mehr
auf meinem kleinen hochgeladen habe und
zwar zum laser ja so krass ist das spiel
jetzt auch nicht weiter geht es darum
dass wir diese ziele hier sind und wir
warum davor den menschen ja schönen dank
auch ich überfällig dann auch nächsten
montag keine ahnung warum hier vorne
solle komische frau auf dem boden liegt
aber wir können einfach mal drücken
dann lenken wir sie das hört sich jetzt
falsch an wir lecken die jetzt auf jeden
fall hier mit unserer zunge und können
jetzt einfach mal so machen und dann
schmeißen wir die weg und jetzt ist hier
in der nächste und die haben uns erstmal
ganz freundlich also ja freunde herzlich
willkommen hier heute seitdem monaten
wirklich mal wieder zu einer neuen folge
gold das haben sich sehr viele von euch
mal wieder gewünscht die schon länger
auf meinem kanal abonnent sind weil vor
einigen jahren habe ich ja wirklich
wöchentlich eine folge gold simi liter
hochgeladen und zudem würde ich euch
jetzt gerne auch mal hier
ein mimi einblenden beziehungsweise ein
foto auf dem ich bei instagram markiert
wurde und zwar habe ich mir gedacht dass
ich demnächst das mal wieder mache das
nicht so
ganz kurz habt ihr den menschen da
gerade vom himmel fallen sehen ja
herzlich willkommen bei gut 7 later dem
spiel bei dem alles komplett normal
zugeht ich habe mir auf jeden fall
gedacht dass ich demnächst mal zu beginn
das ja natürlich jetzt ertrinken wir
hier ich habe auf jeden fall gedacht
dass ich demnächst ich wusste dass ich
hier in die kanalisation gehen kann
ja auf jeden fall sind wir jetzt hier
der kanalisation angekommen ich würde
sagen ich glaube wir einfach mal so ein
bisschen weiter und hier ist hier geht
es nicht weiter hier ist alles relativ
dunkel hier vorjahr
mein gott das sind die ninja turtles
oder bin ich hey was geht denn jetzt
hier ab eine ahnung was sie hier
veranstalten nämlich laufen an denen
vorbei und was passiert hier ich bin mal
wieder rausgegangen aus der kanalisation
da vorne ist es mir echt ein bisschen zu
viel geworden allerdings um auf thema
zurückzukommen ich wollte einfach so ein
bisschen eure arbeit mehr wertschätzen
und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht blende
ich jetzt immer zu beginn meiner videos
hier - ein irgendwelche vernarrt
zeichnungen bilder oder irgendwelche
videos oder so auf denen ihr mich bei
instagram markiert also markiert gernet
laser luca auf euren instagram edits von
mir und das hier beispielsweise ist von
lukas ohren hab also allemal lukas ohren
haar folgen falls sie mehr von solchen
witzigen - sehen wollt allerdings widmen
wir uns jetzt wieder gut simulator
jedoch ist das ding so ein bisschen
meinte der sitz der aus spa sind
ich muss los ich wollte mich eigentlich
nur neben den sätzen aber jetzt habe ich
dir irgendwie ins wasser geschleudert
ich würde sagen wir springen mal kurz
hinterher ich würde eigentlich direkt ab
und wollen aber wir können ja mal hier
klicken
hier können wir nicht ja dann sagen wir
einfach der wollte schon immer mal gern
tauchen ich habe diese gott sie mir auf
jeden fall schon ziemlich häufig
gespielt die sache ist der typ liegt da
unten immer noch also ich wünsche dir an
der schönen tauchgang ich habe diese map
hier schon das ein oder andere mal auf
meinem kanal gespielt das ding ist nur
dass ich die map jetzt habe ich jetzt
hab ich hat diese aktien
ich habe diese map noch nie so richtig
erkundet ich hab immer nur ein bisschen
schwach sinn macht und ich meine ganz im
ernst man wird man wird auch an also
jetzt steht er da das ist so das ding an
bord ziviler aber nimmt sich
irgendwelche sachen vor in diesem spiel
und auf dem weg dahin diese sachen
umzusetzen kommen tausend andere dinge
die einen davon abhalten die einen
ablenken und dann fällt auf einmal
plötzlich irgendwie so ein typ ins
wasser und dann findet man die ninja
turtles in der kanalisation und dann
wird vom typ getreten auf java aber ich
glaube wirklich dass eigentlich jeder
auf einem kanal das spiel dezimiert
erkennen sollte was gucken nämlich dann
alles so an die gucken mich auch alle
und jetzt kommt's mir alle wieder weg
ist es euer ernst
das ist dann wenn ich mal einfach so
machen
[Applaus]
ich lauf mal weg und ge sorry das wollte
ich auch nicht
wir waren wir schon mit drin ich weiß es
gar nicht kommen ich darauf rein
oh ja so falsch immer riesenrad ja ist
ja mega entspannt ich hab ich hab nichts
gedrückt ich hab nichts bei der mega
entspannte vater auf jeden fall und auch
die musik nervt absolut gar nicht auf
jeden fall sind jetzt hier auf dem
jahrmarkt und habe ich mich noch nie so
richtig umgesehen was rennt er denn so
dumm lang
der hat doch irgendwas verbrochen komme
jetzt wartet der hier hinter der will
doch safe diesen typen da umbringen oder
so ja okay vielleicht steht er doch
einfach nur falls du uns wasser willst
die gm ich kenne doch helfen
[Musik]
er läuft wieder web.de hat irgendwas vor
ich sage heute verfolgen den jetzt
einfach mal anschauen oder hinläuft ich
habe keinen plan was irgendwie sein sein
ziel ist jetzt läuft dagegen die durch
das ding co habt ihr das gesehen hat im
gegenzug nicht reden das kann doch nicht
wahr sein das ist hier nicht mit mir
ich weiß nicht wo wir hier gerade
ehrlich gesagt okay aha freunde hier
vorne ist hat er will sich verstecken
und hat ihr fordern auch die ganze
brüstung kaputtgemacht ethik ab du wirst
bestraft für deine taten du wirst jetzt
ganz einfach erwartet dass sie es
nämlich gott sie me later und da ist ist
das gut
jetzt gibt es zwei folgt das ist ein
ablenkungsmanöver alter ich merke schon
welser kingsley tja da hat er sich schon
selbst bestraft und die andere person
die hier ist das euer verdammt
der schläger was ist denn jetzt läuft er
hier wieder lang
was ist denn willi ich hab keine ahnung
in was für einer irrenanstalt ich je
gelandet bin hallo ziegeln die ich kann
euch wirklich nicht erklären was hier
abgeht ich kann euch auch nicht sagen
was der sinn von dem spiele weil da gibt
es wirklich einfach keinen sinn
allerdings habe ich mir für die heutige
folge vorgenommen dass wir uns auf
dieser map mal so ein bisschen jahrmarkt
anschauen also das hier ist ja der
jahrmarkt mit dem riesenrad mit der mit
der achterbahn und so weiter und so fort
in der hüpfburg hier fordern sagte
jahrmarkt oder kirmes eigentlich sage
ich auch matthias ich weiß gar nicht
warum ich heute so oft jahrmarkt sagen
ob alles klar du fällst auch erst mal
direkt auf die fresse das ist auf jeden
fall der eingang zu dem der zug keine
ahnung aber ich würde gern rein genau
dankeschön können sie gern hochfahren
jetzt die türen schließen sich das heißt
wir sind jetzt in dem fahrstuhl und der
fahrstuhl fährt nach oben
[Musik]
ich habe keine ahnung allerdings ist
hier gerade das ganze geöffnet worden
und ich kann mich jetzt hier reinstellen
aber nicht ach du kacke
88 grüne 98 heilige mutter gottes
ich bin rausgeflogen und haut noch den
box automaten um also das war auch die
beste achterbahn fahrt meines lebens
dann bisher als allgemeine komplette
aufenthalt auf der krim ist reinster
erfolg was was tun sie denn hier
tschuldigung denken die karte beim smart
nachhaltig der fall ist könnten sie
bitte lassen sie tut geheimcode durch
die mal retten
vielleicht rückt mal kurz dann kann ich
die lecken und dann werde ich mal
hierhin bringen wollten bedanken
bitteschön bei mir jetzt hoffnungslos
schauen wir doch mal was hier vorne bei
der kirmes abgeht
hier vorne es nämlich so ein kleiner
grillplatz so schön machen sich ihr
fleisch bisher ein hammertag für die
ziege auf der kirmes aber ich bin eine
nette siege und holt den ob ich brenne
im wasser wie kann ich wie kann ich im
wasser brennen ja herzlich willkommen
bei gott simulator vorne die frau nicht
mein gott das tut mir leid ich habe eine
frau angezündet
aber sie jauchzen feuchten kurz und
einfach ihr leben allerdings weiß ja gar
nicht was mich jetzt noch riesig machen
sollen ich meine ich war auf der
achterbahn ich war auf der rutsche ich
bin in dem fahrstuhl gewesen da oben
bahn.de nicht kriegen muss weil ich
meiner spieler doch einen kleinen sinn
und zwar er muss man halt so quests
bestehen bzw hier beispielsweise diese
ganzen teile da einsammeln ich hab das
ding jetzt angelegt
kann sein dass sich dadurch jetzt nicht
mehr raus falle aber vorhin war das
schwierigste er den looping verleihen
wir den überstehen aha ok den looping
aber überstanden
aber wir hängen jetzt 88 kacke wir
hängen an dem mein gott das ist ja das
wäre ein absoluter albtraum ein flott
und jetzt jetzt lässt auch noch jetzt
ist okay das ist der arsch von der ziege
wurde an der stelle mich das heutige
video zu beenden meine lieben freunde
werden euch gott sie mir auf meinem
kanal mal wieder gefallen hat dann das
unbedingt ein daumen hoch unter dem
video hier das schaffen wir 50.000 like
das ist ein mega krass und wird zeigen
ihr habt immer noch bock auf diese serie
zog das er aufm einem kanal mittlerweile
schon seit vier jahren oder irgendwie so
aber habe mir macht immer noch spaß und
es gibt immer noch so sei auf viele
sachen zu entdecken schreibt mir zudem
gerne unten die kommentare was ich in
der nächsten folge golfsimulator machen
soll soll ich auf eine ganz andere web
gehen oder solche beispielsweise noch
mal versuchen mit dem helikopter um zu
fliegen
soll ich noch mal ganz andere sachen
machen in dem game schreiben dass keine
kommentare abonniert gern main kanal
falls sie das video dann nicht verpassen
wollte wenn schon dann klickt dann auf
die glocke dann bekommt er eine
benachrichtigung wenn ich was neues hoch
lade und wie bereits gesagt auf
instagram mich gern verlinken auf irgend
welchen bildern dann bekommt den shout
out in meinem neuen video morgen
[Musik]